humain de nous accompagner pendant cette
première demi-heure vous êtes élu de
Paris memb du groupe les républicains
vice-président de la commission des
affaires étrangères de la défense et des
forces armées du Sénat et on va
évidemment parler de l'actualité en
Israël de l'actualité en Ukraine mais
d'abord l'actualité au Parlement
aujourd'hui c'est cette loi immigration
qui fait donc son arrivée à l'Assemblée
nationale et un examen qui pourrait
tourner court parce qu'il y a une motion
de rejet qui a été déposée par
l'opposition si elle est votée le texte
ne serait pas débattu l'examen
s'arrêterait immédiatement est-ce que
vous appelez les députés les
républicains a voté cette motion de
rejet alors moi je dirais déjà que ça
fait 18 mois qu'on a des atermoims des
reports par rapport à cette loi le
gouvernement a beaucoup hésité là on
arrive vraiment au moment en effet où il
faut
décider je pense que ce qui serait
terrible c'est qu'il n'y ait pas de
discussion infinie à l'Assemblée parce
que nous sommes des parlementaires et
que notre travail c'est justement de
discuter de construire la loi pour ma
part
je pense que ça serait vraiment ennuyeux
que que cette motion soit votée que le
texte que le gouvernement peut-être
retire le texte parce que si elle était
votée c'est peut-être ce qui peut se
passer soit qu'elle revienne au Sénat
soit que le texte revienne au Sénat sans
discussion à l'Assemblée donc j'espère
que parce que les républicains ils ont
eux-même déposé une motion de rejet elle
a pas été tirée au sort mais il y en a
une c'est une erreur d'avoir déposé ce
cette motion je dirais pas que c'est une
erreur après je c'est très complexe pour
mes collègues députés LR à l'Assemblée
leur position n'est pas facile en
revanche moi ça me paraît difficile de
s'allier à et fi aux écologistes donc je
pense que il préférable d'avoir une
discussion et après de voir ce qu'il y a
dans ce texte c'est évident que au Sénat
nous avons beaucoup travaillé sur ce
texte et que s'il devait revenir je
dirais dénaturé tellement amander qu'il
n'aurait plus de sens ça ça ne pourrait
pas être possible donc j'espère que
chacun prendra ses respons
responsabilité qu'il y aura une
discussion et qu'après en commission
mixte paritaire on arrivera à un texte
qui convient je rappelle juste que les
Français dans leur grande majorité les
sondages le montrent attendent un texte
avec beaucoup plus de fermeté sur
l'immigration donc ça c'est notre devoir
de politique de répondre à cette attente
mais vous le dites les Français ils
attendent un texte et ils soutiennent
plutôt ce texte du Gouvernement est-ce
que du coup les alr nonont pas beaucoup
à perdre en contribuant à ce qu'il ne
soit pas examiné et à ce qu'il n'entre
pas en vigueur on verra encore une fois
ce que font mes collègues ve députés cet
après-midi ce qui a de certain c'est
qu'il faut qu'il sorte un texte parce
que c'est une attente des Français et
c'est une attente en général on a besoin
de ce texte et qu'il soit qu'il
corresponde le plus le plus possible à
la situation que nous connaissons en
France et donc ça c'est notre devoir de
politique après on va voir ce qui va se
passer demain il y aura un autre texte
sur l'immigration qui qui sera examiné
cette fois au Sénat c'est un texte des
républicains pour une réforme
constitutionnelle pour permettre un
référendum sur l'immigration et pour que
le droit national prime sur le droit
européen sur cette question les
centristes l'ont détricoté en commission
ils ne sont pas d'accord avec vous
est-ce que vous craignez d'être mis en
minorité demain soir alors c'est pareil
hein il y a des discussions qui se font
c'est vrai que les républicains dès le
départ l'ont dit on veut une
modification de la Constitution ça nous
semble essentiel pour pouvoir vraiment
pouvoir légiférer après sur le sujet
immigration sans cette modification on
peut pas le faire donc ça on l'a dit dès
le départ et on le souhaite après nos
amis centristes qui composent la
majorité au Sénat avec nous euh ont
toujours été pour cette modification
donc j'ai un peu de mal à croire que
tout change donc je fais aussi confiance
alors déjà à la à la capacité du
président du Cénat et de ses équipes à à
pouvoir influer leur position et puis à
eux-même à être conscient que que c'est
tout à fait nécessaire donc vous vous
pensez encore que le texte pourra passer
écoutez par nature je suis optimiste et
je pense que la majorité du Sénat saura
prendre ses responsabilités un mot sur
un autre sujet c'est ça concerne un plan
du gouvernement qui a été dévoilé hier
par Aurore berger un plan pour
responsabiliser les parents les parents
qui sont les parents défaillants c'est
ce que dit le gouvernement qui sont
ciblés mise en place de travaux
d'intérêt général pour les parents
défaillants paiement du une contribution
financière pour les parents d'enfants
coupables de dégradation et une amende
pour les parents qui ne se présentent
pas aux audiences qui concernent leurs
enfants vous encourager ces mesures oui
alors j'ai je trouve que c'est très bien
que la ministre ait pris cette décision
parce que il est grand temps qu'on se
rende compte qu'on a besoin d'autorité
qu'on a besoin d'autorité à l'école
qu'on a besoin d'autorité dans les
familles et qu'on a besoin d'autorité
dans la société en général donc je pense
que ce texte va dans le bon sens après
il va falloir le travailler je l'imagine
parce que il y a des choses à
approfondir je n'ai pas tout à fait
compris quelle sera la nature de ces
travaux d'intérêt général j'ai pas tout
à fait compris qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un
parent défaillant je pense qu'il y a un
travail à faire sur ces sujets mais oui
le texte va dans le bon sens on va
parler de l'actualité du Sénat et de
l'actualité internationale vous êtes
vice-présidente on le disait de la
commission des affaires étrangères et de
la Défense le Sénat qui examine ce soir
le budget de la défense alors que
contient-il on va voir ça avec notre
journaliste parlementaire Alexandre
[Musique]
poussa bonjour Alex bonjour Rian bonjour
Catherine Duma bonjour et Alex le budget
de la défense fait partie des budgets
qui connaissent la plus forte hausse et
oui pour l'année 2024 le budget de la
défense s'élève à 47,2 milliards d'euros
c'est-à-dire une hausse de 3,3 milliards
d'euros par rapport à les dernière plus
vir + 7,5 % et notez que ce budget de la
défense il représente désormais 1,9 % de
notre richesse nationale c'est une part
assez élevée quand on se compare à
d'autres pays dans le monde il y a
seulement des pays comme les États-Unis
Israël et la Russie qui ont un ratio
plus élevé et qui consacrent
d'importants moyens à leur défense alors
cette forte hausse du budget des armées
elle s'inscrit dans une trajectoire de
long terme amorcée notamment depuis le
premier quinquenat d'Emmanuel Macron he
depuis 2017 ce ce budget de la défense a
augmenté de 46 % et avec la nouvelle loi
de programmation militaire sur la
période 2024-2030 et bien nos armées
vont bénéficier au total d'un budget de
400 milliards d'euros c'estes 100
milliards d'euros de plus que sur la loi
de programmation précédente c'est une
trajectoire en forte hausse qui
s'explique notamment par la guerre en
Ukraine qui a qui a éclaté en 2022 alors
Alex à quoi va servir cet argent l'année
prochaine et bien d'abord à s'équiper et
à payer d'importantes commandes militair
pour moderniser nos armées avec des
commandes à hauteur de
13,6 milliards d'euros dans ces
commandes militaires il y aura 13 avions
rafales un sous-marin nucléaire
d'attaque Tourville une cyber frégade de
défense et d'intervention ou encore 274
blindés scorpion ça c'est pour les
équipements neuf et puis il y a aussi
des moyens pour entretenir l'équipement
actuel de nos armées dont une partie est
jugée vetuste 5,7 milliards d'euros vont
être consacré à l'entretien et à la
rénovation du matériel soit une hausse
de 15 % de ses moyens de rénovation par
rapport à l'année précédente et puis sur
le plan humain on peut dire que l'armée
française recrute puisque pour l'année
2024 et bien 28000 recrutements sont
prévus pour servir plusieurs effectifs
le renseignement la cyberdéfense les
unités opérationnelles mais ce sont
surtout des recrutements qui vont servir
à palier des départs puisque au total et
bien la hausse nette des effectifs de
l'armée s'élève à 400 emplois à temps
plein Catherine Duma ce budget de la
défense il est assez important assez
ambitieux pour faire face aux nouvelles
menaces extérieures autour du continent
européen oui alors alors vous l'avez
très bien décrit vous avez tout dit bien
sûr il est c'est très important qu'il
soit en augmentation et nous l'avons
salué le contexte international
évidemment avec des crises qui se
multiplient de
guerres évidemment rendait indispensable
cet effort qui d'ailleurs avait commencé
auparavant donc nous sommes tout à fait
satisfaits après je dirais deux choses
et vous l'avez vous-même soulevé c'est
un est-ce qu'on est prêt à une guerre de
haute intensité et ça c'est pas du tout
certain vous avez parler du sujet des
munitions c'est le sujet très très
important par rapport à ce budget et là
on a encore beaucoup à faire il faut
qu'on travail sur notre tissu industriel
de l'armement euh aider les grandes
entreprises à pouvoir en effet faire
qu'on puisse se réarmer qu'on on dispose
des munitions nécessaires ce qui n'est
pas toujours le cas sur le terrain j'ai
pu voir que on allait par exemple la
frégate langdoc dont on parle en mer
Rouge qui a fait l'objet de de qui
allait fait l'objet d'attaque de drone
j'avais pu constater moi-même qu'à
l'époque il y avait encore des
équipements qui n'étaient pas tout à
fait satisfaisants donc on voit bien
l'importance d'un équipement comme
celui-ci dans un contexte de guerre et
dans un contexte de crise en mer Rouge
donc un gros effort à faire sur les
munitions et aussi sur les petits
sous-traitants qui sont très importants
dans la chaîne de de de de pour les
munition et donc il y a cet effort à
faire et puis deuxième peut-être point à
dire c'est vous en avez parlé les
effectifs sur les effectifs vous avez
dit le sold c'est 450 emplois évidemment
ça interroge tout ceux que nous avons
auditionné les chefs d'état-major le
montrent il y a un problème
d'attractivité de notre armée il faut
qu'on travaille sur ce sujet pour
nouveau faire que des jeunes viennent
travailler dans l'armée ça suppose de
travailler bien sur les rémunérations
bien entendu sur aussi la vie dans
l'armée la vie des familles le logement
donc la commission des affaires
étrangères et de la défense est très
mobilisé sur ces sujets donc pour
l'instant il y a pas assez de moyens
pour rendre plus attractif les méti
milita gr pour rendre ces métiers
attractif qui passe par encore une fois
leurs conditions de vie leur
rémunération mais aussi certainement un
travail à faire au sommet de l'État pour
expliquer aux Français combien la
défense est très très importante pour
notre pays vous citiez nos faiblesses en
terme de munition est-ce qu'elles ont
été aggravé aussi par notre aide
militaire importante à l'Ukraine alors
forcément ça pose question et puisqu'on
on apporte une aide à l'Ukraine il faut
d'autant plus qu'on ait des réserves de
munition et c'est vrai je vous cite le
le le cas de de de nos armées de la
Marine qui est en renfort d'autres
armées c'est très important qu'on puisse
dans ce contexte de guerre et de crise
qu'on puisse vraiment faire de gros
efforts et c'est là où notre tissu
industriel est très très important donc
ça veut dire aujourd'hui l'armée
française n'est pas prête en terme
d'équipement deion à un conflit de haute
intensité ça bien sûr et il faut euh en
effet alors je sais pas s'il faut s'y
préparer mais en tout cas il faut en
tenir compte et il faut faire encore
d'autres efforts puis il y a aussi des
moyens importants pour l'entretien et la
rénovation des équipements actuels ça
vous qui sont jugés vetust il laissaient
à désirer ces équipement alors il faut
pas dramatiser mais pour certains
d'entre eux il y a en effet un gros
travail à faire il y a en effet un
travail de de rénovation euh de
d'équipement en attendant d'en avoir de
nouveau mais tout ça encore une fois ça
doit se faire avec avec tous les
professionnels qui travaillent sur ces
sujets il faut aussi se moderniser on
parlait des effectifs investir notamment
dans la cyberdéfense on le fait assez on
le fait assez bien sû alors oui en tout
cas il y a une vraie prise de conscience
mais il faut le faire de plus en plus
parce que en effet on voit que la guerre
peut prendre d'autres aspects d'autres
formes et il faut être prêt et donc dans
le budget il y a des lignes budgétaires
prévues pour ceci mais il faudra
certainement par rapport à certains
types d'attaqu pouvoir mettre encore
plus de moy moy à l'avenir et nous y
veillerons à la commission merci Alex à
tout à l'heureci à tout à l'heure on
parlera de la loi immigration exactement
on va parler on va continuer à parler de
ces sujet de l'actualité internationale
à commencé par Israël on l'a vu dans le
journal Catherine Juma et les
bombardements se poursuivent dans la
bande de Gaza et ce weekend le Hamas a
dit qu'aucun otage ne sortira vivant de
gazas sans négociation benamin netanahou
lui appelle le Hamas à se rendre parle
de guerre juste est-ce qu'on est
aujourd'hui dans une impasse on est dans
une situation très difficile on comprend
que évidemment Israël on comprend tout à
fait la réaction et on est avec Israël
d'autre part on a le sujet quand même de
de la Palestine il faudra trouver une
solution politique à la Palestine à un
moment ou un autre et le plus vite
possible on a évidemment le sujet à très
très court terme des otages parce que si
on a pu en faire sortir un certain
nombre il y en a encore beaucoup euh et
donc oui la situation est difficile et
j' dirais que chaque pays est interpellé
et doit jouer son rôle dans l'issue qui
doit être le plus favorable mais c'est
vrai que la situation est difficile
aujourd'hui vous revenez de Washington
vous vous y étiez en tant que membre
suppléante de l'Assemblée parlementaire
de l'OTAN et vous y étiez au moment où
le Congrès américain a échoué a avancé
sur une grande enveloppe de plus de 106
milliards de dollars réclamé par Joe
Biden et comprenant des fonds pour
l'Ukraine et pour Israël est-ce que cela
vous inquiète alors à Washington en
effet dans le cadre de l'Assemblée
parlementaire de l'OTAN nous avons
largement évoqué ces sujets euh avec
tous les parlementaires des pays de
l'Alliance euh il y a une grande
inquiétude de toute part nous l'avons
d'ailleurs évoqué aussi avec notre
ambassadeur euh notre ambassadeur
français à Washington Laurent Billy euh
oui c'est beaucoup beaucoup d'inquiétude
alors vous l'avez dit au même moment euh
le Congrès euh discutait avec le
président des États-Unis qui demande de
plus de 100 milliards pour en donner une
trentaine à Israël et plus de 60 à
l'Ukraine pour l'instant on est dans
l'impasse bon j'ai j'ose espérer que que
ça va avancer je fais quand même
confiance au au talent je dirais de du
président des États-Unis qui était un
parlementaire à guéri pendant tellement
d'années qui connaît tellement bien le
monde parlementaire espérons qu'il
arrive à obtenir cette rallonge qui est
absolument indispensable Joe Biden qui a
invité demain à la Maison Blanche
volodimir Zelenski est-ce que c'est un
un signal qui est important au moment où
il y a peut-être un risque que la guerre
en Ukraine soit oubliée oui tout à fait
je pense que on le voit bien d'ailleurs
le président Zelenski s'est rendu en
Argentine à l'investiture de ravier met
parce que il y a un sujet par rapport à
la prochaine COP 20 dont l'Argentine est
membre et dont la présidence rassurée
par le Brésil donc on voit bien
l'importance de ce type de voyage euh il
va rencontrer le président des
États-Unis ça montre à la fois le sujet
gravissime mais ça montre aussi que les
Ukrainiens sont dans une ne sont pas du
tout dans une résignation au contraire
ils sont vraiment très très déterminés
c'est un peuple très résilient et donc
voilà ils font tout ce qu'il faut pour
trouver les solutions et du côté de
l'Union européenne ce matin ursola
verleon donne une interview au journal
Le Paris aujourd'hui en France elle dit
que le soutien à Kiev doit rester sans
faille et elle dit une victoire russe en
Ukraine serait lourde de menace pour ses
voisins européens vous part sû bien sûr
que je partage d'autant plus que on est
dans une situation très à part en Russie
il va y avoir une élection au mois de
mars le président Poutine a annoncé que
il repartait pour un 5e mandat c'est
maaise nouvelle une mauvaise nouvelle
c'est une nouvelle qu'on prend
malheureusement on n' pas beaucoup de on
peut pas agir là-dessus on pouvait s'y
attendre donc que voilà ne soyons pas
hypocrite en revanche lui au-delà de la
guerre contre l'Ukraine maintenant il
est quand même dans une guerre contre
l'Occident donc ça c'est une mauvaise
nouvelle et c'est très bien qu'au niveau
de l'Europe en effet on envoie des
messages forts mais ce message je recela
v lyen est-ce que pour vous il est le
signe qu'il a un risque que le soutien
des 27 s'affaiblisse alors je pense pas
que le soutien des 27 va s'affaiblir
mais je pense que en effet bien bientôt
3 ans au mois de mars hein dans cette
guerre donc le temps passe le temps
passe et il y a un phénomène d'usure il
y a un phénomène et puis sur le terrain
des grandes difficultés il y a aussi un
autre conflit qui fait que tout ça est
très complexe et c'est vrai que il faut
être très très vigilant et rapporter un
soutien à la foie morale et puis
effectif surtout à l'Ukraine on va
terminer en parlant de ce qui se passe
du côté de Paris et pour ça on va
rejoindre ja Paquier bonjour Jacques
merci beaucoup d'être avec ns directeurs
de la rédaction du journal du Grand
Paris Jacques avec vous on va parler
d'un tout autre sujet on va parler du
Conseil de Paris il se réunit cette
semaine pour examiner le budget
2024 absolument oui madame Duma comme
vous le le savez le groupe changer
Paris demande une série de de choses
notamment concernant le budget 2024 et
les finances de la Ville de Paris plus
globalement il demande de mettre vous
demander mettre en place une stratégie
de désendettement de mettre en place une
revue générale des dépenses de la ville
de Paris de produire un scénario
d'évolution des recettes de droit de
mutation qui sont touché par la crise de
l'immobilier est-ce àd et et on le
comprend comme ça que vous êtes inquiète
sur la la trajectoire financière de de
la ville de Paris madame la sénatrice
oui bonjour monsieur Pasquet alors oui
si vous me demandez si je suis inquiète
si nous sommes inquiets avec Rachid
adati la présidente de notre groupe que
vous avez cité bien sûr que nous le
sommes d'ailleurs ça fait 3 ans que nous
le disons euh depuis 2020 à chaque
budget nous n'arrêtons pas de d'alerter
euh et nous voyons que à chaque budget
et bien la dette grandit là on va être à
10 milliards on parle même de 12 pour
2026 alors évidemment nous redemandons
un certain nombre de mesures très fortes
notre groupe y tient beaucoup euh
notamment il faut absolument qu'on ait
un audit complet en effet des finances
qu'on sache absolument où on va j'ajoute
qu'il y a quand même la question des
Jeux Olympiques on ne sait pas si on
dépassera le budget ou pas mais on a
besoin d'indicateurs on a besoin de
savoir si on dépasse ce qui se passe de
garantie pour la suite donc oui à un
moment où Paris est de plus en plus mal
géré et surtout c'est ça que je voudrais
dire c'est que la qualité de service aux
Parisiens n'est pas là évidemment c'est
tout le contraire on a une ville sale
insécure dans un désordre l'espace
public est dans un désordre total on est
une démotivation du personnel ça c'est
très très important on le dit jamais
assez il y a énormément de
fonctionnaires à Paris qui ne sont pas
gérés qui sont complètement démotivés
donc et à ce moment-là on a une
situation financière gravissime alors
oui nous sommes très inquiet à ce sujet
par exemple pi pierif Bournazel suggère
ou demande que je crois un un un
fonctionnaire sur trois ne soit pas
remplacé lors de son départ à la
retraite est-ce que est-ce que vous
pensez qu'il y a trop de fonctionnaires
à Paris alors ce que dit Pierry
Bournazel nous avons travaillé dessus
dans notre groupe depuis bien longtemps
le sujet comme je vous le dis il y av il
y a à Paris une très belle
administration qui
malheureusement maintenant est laissée
sans boussole et depuis un moment donc
après le problème c'est pas de savoir
s'il y a trop de fonctionnaires c'est de
savoir comment ils sont employés comment
ils sont utilisés notamment dans les
arrondissements c'est ça aussi le vrai
sujet le sujet c'est que il faut que il
y ait une certaine liberté dans les
arrondissements que les maires
d'arrondissement puissent utiliser
intelligemment ses fonctionnaires ce
sont eux qui savent comment les utiliser
euh dans les différents services et les
que l'on doit rendre au parisiens donc
c'est ça le sujet c'est plutôt encore
une fois une gouvernance de qui soit
bien mieux faite pour aujourd'hui il n'y
a pas de gouvernance pour ainsi dire euh
et malheureusement et et c'est vrai et
donc redonner une motivation le donner
des moyens d'agir organiser tout cela et
c'est ça qui est très important après il
faut en effet voir qui est où qui fait
quoi dans quelle direction et il y a
certainement un travail à faire à ce
sujet Jacques il sera aussi question du
périphérique parisien et des limitation
de vitesse puisquealgo veut limiter le
périf à 50
km/h absolument ce sera débattu dans le
cadre du Plan Climat 2024 2030 madame
Duma quelle est votre position il y a il
y a un débat sur l'opportunité de ces
mesure est-ce qu'elles vont
véritablement aboutir à une réduction de
la pollution des gaz à effets de serre à
une réduction du bruit qui serait
bénéfique aux parisiens ou est-ce que au
contraire vous vous pensez que ce ne
sera pas le cas et puis il y a un petit
débat sur la ou un grand débat sur le
juridique est-ce qu'il revient à la
ville de Paris selon vous de trancher ce
débat Clément bon estime que ça relève
de l'État et que la mairie de Paris ne
peut rien faire sans l'aval de l'État
oui alors vous parlez de Clément baun il
y a je dirais une guerre des échos pour
pour parler du périphérique en ce moment
hein entre le ministre qui est délégué
au transports la région la mer de Paris
qui elle alors tout d'un coup en retour
de Tahiti trouve que tout d'un coup il
faut mettre le périphérique à 50 kmh ça
la la prise subitement on voit bien que
en ce qui la concerne c'est un écran de
fumée pour qu'on parle pas d'autres
chose d'ailleurs je dirais que elle est
très peu concerné en fait dans la
pratique elle suit très peu ses sujets
mais tout d'un coup elle veut le mettre
à 50 km/h moi ce que je dis dira c'est
qu'il faut être sérieux le périphérique
c'est vous vous y opposerez euh alors
attendez je je voudrais juste rappeler
ce que c'est que le le périphérique
c'est un boulevard qui existe depuis
1973 c'est 35 km et c'est fait pourquoi
pour faciliter l'entrée dans Paris ou
faciliter le contournement de Paris ça
concerne 22 communes limitrophes qui
était énorme trois départements
notamment aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que
c'est le périphérique c'est une voie
communale donc ça veut dire que Madame
Hidalgo peut faire ce qu'elle veut et
décider en effet de le mettre à 50 de
fermer une voie pour la circulation
enfin de la consacrer à un autre type de
circulation et cetera et cetera et en
plus quand ça la prend et cetera donc ça
ce n'est pas possible donc le sujet
au-delà de des 50 kmh est de savoir si
on on sera d'accord ou pas c'est de
savoir qui décide et c'est pour ça que
avec mes deux autres collègues sénateurs
de Paris maises deux colistier nous
avons pris une initiative pour faire une
proposition de loi pour faire que la
gouvernance du périphérique change et
que la police de circulation revienne à
l'État c'est-à-dire au préfet et non
plus à la mer de Paris qui peut décider
ce qu'elle veut quand elle veut pour des
raisons d'ailleurs qui sont autres que
celles de l'intérêt de tous les usagers
du périphérique qui je le rappelle ne
sont pas que parisiens ni franciliens
mais sont nationaux c'est une voie
nationale le périphérique un dernier mot
Catherine Duma parce que le tempsfil sur
les Jeux Olympiques et notamment la
cérémonie d'ouverture qui est prévu sur
la scène est-ce qu'il faut il renoncé
hier dans le Parisien Eric sootti parle
d'un plombé plutôt laffire dans un
endroit fermé comme le Stade de France
vous êtes d'accord avec ça non moi je
pense que sur les Jeux Olympiques déjà
il faut euh à prendre les mesures
nécessaires pour que tout se passe bien
mais c'est évident que c'est quelque
chose qui approche donc forcément il y a
des craintes qui se font jour et on
mesure plus on approche de la date je
crois que c'est 230 jours à peu près
plus on approche on mesure les
difficultés après ce qui importe c'est
d'être responsable et de pas lier à ses
difficultés et d'anticiper les risques
et les problèmes c'est surtout ça qui
est important je pense qu'il y a des
efforts qui sont faits par l'État
nous-même au Sénat on s'est beaucoup
intéressé dans la lopmie la loi
d'organisation et de programmation de la
sécurité intérieure on a mis des mesures
sur la sécurité sur la lutte antidrone
et cetera et cetera donc je pense que il
faut que l'État fasse son travail la
ville de Paris aussi et faire en sorte
que tout ceci se passe bien mais pour
que ça reste sur la scène tant oui c'est
ce qui est prévu tant sur la sécurité il
y a d'autres sujets hein que sur le prix
des billets et cetera et cetera il y il
y a et les transports dont on vient de
parler je pense qu'il faut plutôt
anticiper et être prêt et je dirais
aussi attention attention à tout ce
qu'on dit sur les Jeux Olympiques ce qui
importe aussi c'est pas d'avoir que des
craintes ou des incertitudes c'est aussi
d'avoir cet esprit olympique que vont
avoir nos athlètes que nous les
politiques on l' aussi un peu
merci merci Jacques Paquier la Une du
journal du Grand Paris l'année noire de
l'immobilier sera 2024 c'est à la Une de
votre journal merci beaucoup Jacques
pquy à très vite merci Catherine lumain
d'avoir été notre invité pendant cette
première demi-heure